i'm ugly i'm ugly what's happening how
do i look how do i look how dark what
does it look like what does it look like
what does it look like i'm like why
would someone do this to me
no one's ever gonna marry me like i'm
finished like i'm i've been destroyed
[Music]
so that day i remember that day
clearly um i woke up
i had a shift i was working victoria's
secrets in stratford westfield
so as i got off the bus
i was on the phone to my boyfriend at a
time
on the opposite side of me
a black figure
in a black just wanted a big black
jacket
black trousers black shoes
and then the person was wearing a nikon
and i remember being on the phone like
literally on the phone here and i was
talking to my ex
and then as i turn
i remember seeing this figure
and it just took me a couple of seconds
the figure was
this cold stair this cold
cold cold stare
all i feel is a big
a massive massive massive
splash and i'm
like oh my god and
i start screaming off the top of my
lungs
i started to feel like something like
just burning and eating at my skin and
just
i was hot i was sweaty it was just it
stunk like there was a such a strong
chemical oh my gosh like i felt like my
nose was literally gonna just
disintegrate this this is acid someone
whose friend acid at me someone has
friend acid at me
and i sprinted i think that's the
fastest i've ever
ran i was shaking i was screaming
i literally thought someone was trying
to kill me
and as i got to my door literally
banging on my door banging on my door
and i remember my mom opening the door
and then my godmother saw me and she was
like naomi up the stairs up the stairs
now
immediately quickly quickly you know
she's literally got the cold water
franklin water my face
and we don't even realize that it's the
thing has basically been burning into my
blouse
burning into my leggings i'm talking
gibberish
i'm screaming i'm shouting i'm shaking
i'm like why would someone do this to me
i'm ugly i'm ugly what's happening how
do i look how do i look how do i like
what does it look like what does it look
like what does it look like
i'm shouting on my cousin sarah am i
ugly just telling the truth i'm ugly
tell me the truth
no one really knew what to say and i've
looked into the mirror
for the first time and um
my face was literally blue purple
and pink and i just had
mucus mucus tons of mucus just
running down my face running down my
face running down my face
and the police have come in and they're
just like
what happened and they're like we've
never
seen anything like this
before
that was um very very tough to hear
the ambulance has come
and um my godmother i told my godmother
to come into the ambulance because i
don't want my mom to
as i get to white chapel hospital i'm
basically
the you know being pulled on the bed
and i've been literally i'm having
nurses and doctors literally poking at
me
by this time they've taken me into a
room like which is like an industrial
shower and they've
wheeled me in and then they've got this
massive
massive shower that's freezing
cold ice cold and they've put me under
and they're washing me my skin is still
burning
and they're washing the acid off with
this
massive massive shower and i'm literally
screaming
at the top of my lungs the
pain of the burn and then the pain of
the
freezing water was just
it was just too much for me to handle as
i've seen the burns i'm in hospital
the burns have kind of
gone hard so i'm basically told i'm
going to have surgery and i'm going to
basically peel off
the dead the dry burnt skin and
basically i was sat down and told that
i'm basically never
gonna look the same again i'm not gonna
look like naomi ever again
i was like no one's ever gonna marry me
like i'm
finished like i'm i've been destroyed no
one's ever going to marry me no one's
ever going to be with me
can you just talk about how you met your
attacker so
i met mary in san angelo's aslan school
i'd say the friendship was very
turbulent
so there's times where we would have
like phone conversations
late at night i would literally be
speaking to her probably like for hours
two three hours the day before and the
next day i'd come to school
and i would you know hi mary and she
would give me the most
coldest coldest stare
i think i've ever experienced in my life
and the more i ignored her the more i
hung out with other friends
the more cold and kind of angry she
would become
one random the most randomest day
for my boyfriend at times to call me and
be like
um someone's basically text me saying
that you're seeing someone else
and i was just like okay
first of all i'm not sleeping with other
men
prior to my knowledge mary can be weird
but to take that step forward and do
things like that
that wasn't the kind of person i saw her
as so when
my ex-boyfriend finally revealed to me
who it was
i was boiling like i was boiling with
rage
um boiling with anger
so i said okay i'm gonna calm down and
i'm gonna call her
and she was just very mean she was like
i don't care
you're just trying to feel sorry for
yourself i'm not here to feel sorry for
you
she was so angry she wanted to do this
and that
she was gonna fight me i just told her
that you have to take
responsibility for how you act towards
me and what comes out of your mouth
and obviously from now on now on i'll be
very careful
of what i say to you and she apologized
she was like you know
she's sorry um
that she's missed me how have i been and
that she didn't really mean
you know what she said she was just
angry
fast forward to me having my surgeries
leaving hospital
i'd lost my eyelid on my right eye
and um you know i was just in a lot of
pain i had a raw
you know raw leg where i just had my um
skin grafts
you know removed to put skin on my face
and my other burns
um and i had a birthday party a surprise
birthday party which was thrown by
my boyfriend at the time i'm being
overwhelmed
and just seen all my family and friends
there friends from my workplace
and some of my friends from school and
everything and i was like oh you know
everyone's here
so i felt really loved i felt loved and
then
mary had arrived i remember she came
and i was sitting down in a chair and
she sat beside me and then she had her
head in her hands and she started crying
so i remember rubbing her back telling
her do you know what i'll be fine this
will like blow over i'll give me a
couple of months and i'll be back to
good
i'll be back in a better place i was
like i don't want you guys to worry
about me
i was like stop crying stop crying stop
crying like it's okay at least i'm alive
how did you end up finding out that it
was her dad
and when my story got to the press um it
had to be taken on by the homicide team
which is scotland yard because it was a
serious case
they found the footage of her from
stratford following me
to barking station and basically the
gray bag
she was carrying on the cctv um
[Music]
the grey bag she was currently on cctv
was basically found in house
that's how they found out it was her
that did it and the police said you know
she basically followed you from work all
the way home
and dusts you with suffering
acid in attempts to basically
maim and disfigure you
for me the trial i saw a complete
different side to her
somebody was almost like someone that i
had never met before
it was someone like you know it was like
someone that i
didn't even know speaking
um she accused me of basically for an
acid on myself to basically look to be
like katie piper
because she had gained success after her
incident um so basically i was inspired
by her story and
it was said that i did the same to
myself
to ghana fame which is so stupid
what you know young girl for acid on
herself
just for sympathy or fame she was
sentenced for i think basically like
is it 12 years and she had to do six
she's been released now last year uh
yeah what did you feel like at that
point
i don't hate her um there's
probably i have forgiven her to a
certain extent but
it hasn't been easy for me to deal with
what's happened emotionally and
physically
i've managed to pull the positive out of
this experience and continue to strive
and continue to heal and recover every
day
and to become a better and wiser person
every day
and to be more kind and more loving to
myself and i'm proud of who i
am today and i'm proud that you know
i'm this woman that has overcome you
know
such adversity and tragedy
and sorrow and loss and betrayal and
i thank god for allowing me to still
have a kind and soft heart
i was just a foot soldier you know i was
a foot soldier i wasn't nowhere up in
the ranking
but again i was always putting myself in
those situations i was always putting
myself in danger
led me down the path of having guns and
selling drugs
and doing crime i remember the first
time i saw someone get stabbed and it
was like
didn't even phase me